Doctor Who on the dumb time no seriously
Doctor Who I can't recognize the
protagonist of the BBC's venerable
science-fiction series anymore and it's
not because he does battle with high def
CG aliens instead of pixelated purple
clouds like he did in the show's
nineteen seventies havior it's because
the latest version of the character only
seems to hold a doctorate in retro
sexual fashion where and empathic
encounter sessions doctor who was
supposed to be a cosmic mr. fixing
crisscrossing time and space to thwart
robot overlords and disable doomsday
devices with his preternatural
engineering skills but now he's more of
a psychoanalytical shaymin who helps
alien beings unlock their deeper
emotional truths what happened to the
doctor using his know-how and ingenuity
to overcome adversity look at that what
could possibly go wrong can someone
please send this nine hundred year old
Gallifrey into an interstellar DeVry
Institute where he can relearn the
fundamentals of galaxy saving also
bowties are cool scarfs are cooler than
bowties
subscribe to the wire channel for more
rants from me the angry nerd